las sirenas alertan de una nueva amenaza
sobre mikko live es una señal de que se
debe buscar protección como lo hace este
grupo de madres e hijas que pasan la
mayor parte del tiempo en estos refugios
legados de la segunda guerra mundial
nos
da mucho miedo durante la noche quedarse
en casa tenemos niños por eso venimos
aquí también durante el día
y los niños se sienten aquí más
protegidos que en la casa de sitios
elisabeth no solamente teme por su hija
cada alarma le recuerda que su marido
está en el frente defendiendo la ciudad
tenemos miedo de las explosiones
punto de las explosiones cercanas a
nosotros
tenemos mucho miedo
boeing va camino a visitar su
apartamento que tuvo que abandonar días
atrás cuando fue atacado por una serie
de misiles rusos
esto es muy peligroso en cada jardín ha
caído un cohete de
bomba
la mitad de la población de 500.000
habitantes abandonado mykolaiv una
ciudad estratégica para moscú si la
controla podrá tener acceso directo al
puerto de odessa y cerrar la
comunicación del resto de ucrania con el
mar pero amor adquiere prima papa daña
aquí impacto del cohete directamente
éste fue lanzado desde una población a
más o menos 70 kilómetros
de tapachula
luego viene a darle vuelta a su casa o
inhabitables
cuenta que celebró su 70 cumpleaños en
uno de esos refugios subterráneos
no tengo ninguna opción para irme del
país no tengo familiares ni amigos en el
extranjero no quiero convertirme en una
molestia para nadie por eso me quedaré a
la espera de mejores tiempos
a las afueras de la morgue
esta familia llora la muerte del padre
de anna
estaba en un colegio y una bomba cayó en
el edificio tax solo pudimos encontrarlo
a los tres días solo hoy el destino de
mykolaiv es clave para el futuro de
ucrania y aquí saben que el precio que
tendrán que pagar por ello es bastante
grande temen incluso el asedio como ya
sucede en la ciudad cercana de mariupol
[Música]